olá sejam todos bem vindos
eu não sei se vocês já se perguntar em
algum momento da vida de vocês que é
sucesso
quem sabe essa pergunta ela pareça
travestida de outras expressões o nosso
dia a dia como será que eu tô indo no
caminho certo
será que aquilo que eu escolhi pra mim
pessoal e profissionalmente time levando
o rumo
aquilo que um dia eu sonhei ou imaginei
pra mim essa palavra sucesso
muitas vezes ela é vista por algumas
pessoas com certo tabu com uma certa
resistência
afinal de contas parece que
culturalmente a gente tem uma certa
resistência em assumir que a gente quer
trilhar o caminho do sucesso
eu gosto de uma concepção bastante
orgânica bastante biológica de qualquer
ser vivo ele está nesse momento do
organismo mais simples unicelulares até
a nossa complexidade como ser humano
buscando o sucesso nós como seres vivos
buscamos um sucesso natural um sucesso
biológico que significa permanecer vivos
só que nós humanos dotados de um cérebro
altamente complexo e de capacidades
cognitivas inimagináveis
também encaminhamos dia após dia
consciente ou inconscientemente na busca
de um sucesso social em um lugar
diferente uma forma de ser reconhecido
pelas pessoas de ser visto pelos outros
e não há nada de errado com isso no meu
dia a dia profissional eu tenho o
privilégio de conviver com pessoas das
mais variadas idades trabalhando com
negócios nos mais diferentes possíveis
empresários experientes de pessoas que
estão empreendendo a partir de um sonho
e todas elas estão buscando o seu
sucesso
outras duas grandes perguntas pra gente
se fazer a respeito do sucesso é o que
nós utilizamos como referencial para
determinar o nosso ponto de sucesso e
mais o que nós usamos como referencial
para determinar aquilo que nós vamos
fazer é nível de esforço e de atitude
para chegar no nosso sucesso e essa
pergunta traz consigo outra
diz será que o que nós determinamos como
o nosso sucesso
os esforços que nós fazemos para chegar
lá eles são realmente orgânicos
eles partem de dentro de nós
eles estão relacionados com o nosso dna
ou será que às vezes nós caminhamos em
busca de um sucesso que a gente pode
chamá-lo de transgênico essa marca e se
te dentro desse triângulo amarelo ela
ficou bastante conhecida para todos nós
alguns anos atrás quando começou a
aparecer embalagens de alimentos
especialmente e um alimento que foi é
considerado transgênica porque foi
modificado modificado geneticamente
trazendo insumos pedaços material
genético de tantos outros alimentos
plantas para chegar num determinado
resultado e me parece que nós como
pessoas também acabamos tendo muitas
vezes a buscar pedaços resquícios de
material genético do sucesso dos outros
na hora de configurar aquilo que nós
queremos como o nosso caminho como o
nosso destino como nosso sucesso e me
parece que assim como é na indústria
muitas vezes o material genético que vem
de uma outra de um outro elemento ele
tenta acelerar o processo de crescimento
nós também tentamos trilhar um caminho
do sucesso que seja mais fácil que seja
mais rápido
onde nós possamos ser reconhecido num
passe de mágica onde sem muito esforço
com um esforço que já foi reproduzido
por alguém a gente possa conquistar o
tão sonhado sucesso que cada um de nós
tem e quem sabe a gente possa concordar
que nos dias de hoje a gente tem muito
limpa disponibilidade de muita
informação tudo aquilo que pode em tese
ajudar a gente chegar num sucesso mais
rápido um sucesso mais fácil certamente
vocês já se deram conta que quando a
gente abre o nosso celular abre nossos
smartphones
a gente tem na palma da mão a técnica
utilizada para quem já chegou no seu
sucesso
o case da grande empresa de fora do país
às vezes que diz como deve as coisas
serem feitas algumas pessoas dizendo que
o horário que a gente acorda que
determina se a gente vai ou não ter
sucesso e nós quem sabe ficamos nos
questionando será que eu devo me
apropriar desse material genético do
sucesso dos outros
ou será que eu devo olhar para dentro de
mim mesmo e encontrar aquilo que
organicamente faça sentido porque se não
fizer sentido para mim dificilmente vai
fazer sentido para os outros nós podemos
dizer que a gente vive num mundo numa
sociedade onde a gente está dentro de um
paradoxo da abundância
essa expressão ela surgiu quando se
estuda o desenvolvimento econômico de
países de nações onde a gente
incrivelmente percebe que países onde há
uma grande abundância de recursos
naturais disponíveis não são aqueles em
que há o maior nível de desenvolvimento
e isso é completamente paradoxal me
parece que isso pode acontecer porque a
gente perceber que reside num espaço
mora num lugar vive numa nação altamente
rico em recursos naturais
não é necessário um grande esforço para
a gente ser bem sucedido ao sobreviver
nesse local
o contrário também é verdadeiro países
em nações em essa mesma condição acabam
fazendo um esforço muito grande para
poder se destacar
nós como pessoas como empresários como
estudantes como potenciais
empreendedores também vivemos no meio
desse paradoxo onde essa alta gama de
informação disponível sobre o sucesso de
todo mundo gera uma enorme pobreza de
atenção a nosso próprio respeito
nós conhecemos o que levou empresas
pessoas e profissionais a serem bem
sucedidos nós invejamos muitas vezes a
iniciativa dos outros e nós estamos cada
vez mais desatentos aquilo que acontece
dentro de cada um de nós
quanto mais informação a disponível -
atenção nós damos aquilo que é genuíno
que é nosso que faz parte do meu e do
seu dna
esse paradoxo ele se repete dia após dia
e se a gente começar a ficar um pouco
mais atento
quem sabe a gente possa perceber que
quanto mais limitação de iniciativas a
no mercado - inspiração vem atrás disso
e basta a gente perceber quando uma
empresa quando um negócio bem sucedido
começa a se mostrar vários outros vêm
exatamente fazendo a mesma coisa
quanto mais limitação menos inspiração a
o paradoxo continua
quanto mais comparação nós fazemos com o
nosso caminho com nosso critério com o
nosso crivo de casting que é sucesso
comparado com as outras pessoas
- existe o nosso dna
quanto mais preocupado em buscar
partículas genéticas do sucesso dos
outros a gente está
- a gente está disposto a ampliar e
potencializar aquilo que é genuíno de
cada um de nós aquilo que está dentro de
nós e que a gente muitas vezes valoriza
e trata como se fosse inclusive um
problema ou um defeito que nós tenhamos
o paradoxo segue
quanto mais atalhos a gente busca
- o nosso caminho genuíno é traçado é
partilhado com as outras pessoas e como
consequência também não vai ser
alcançado atalhos podem nos levar
caminhos mais rápidos e mais fáceis mais
atalhos foram feitos por pessoas que já
passaram por lá e se a gente realmente é
um caminho orgânico para aquilo que a
gente atribui como nosso sucesso
nós vamos ter que está disposto a
trilhar o nosso caminho
mas o nosso caminho e - atalhos
nós vivemos um paradoxo de muita imagem
cada vez mais imagem ea preocupação
exacerbada com aquilo que a gente
comunica e - essência tem carregado
nós recebemos diariamente orientações
que o fim da nossa rede social precisa
ser harmônico ele tem que ter cores
determinadas e nós vamos criando um
ambiente de uma imagem comunicada que
muitas vezes não é entregue
realidade dias atrás eu tive
oportunidade de escrever sobre isso que
eu gostaria muito que o zelo o carinho e
atenção que todos nós temos em comunicar
digitalmente a nossa imagem aquilo que a
gente faz ele se perpetuasse na hora que
a gente tem um momento da entrega real e
do contato com as pessoas porque é nesse
momento que se provas e artificial ou se
é orgânico seja genuíno ou se é fruto de
enxertos de dna de tantas outras pessoas
que a gente vai cruzando e vai se
inspirando no meio do caminho
esse paradoxo nos leva para um caminho
de cada vez mais a ansiedade e à medida
que a gente fica ansioso nos comparando
uns com os outros a gente vai deixando
de lado aquilo que é o mais importante
nas nossas escolhas pessoais ou nos
nossos caminhos profissionais que é o
nosso propósito
quanto mais ansiedade mais distante a
gente fica do propósito ea soma de tudo
isso poderia ser sintetizado nesse
último paradoxo quanto mais artificial
são as ações nos trilhos os caminhos e
os objetivos que a gente tem para nossa
vida - orgânicos - genuínos -
verdadeiros nós somos essa frase quem
sabe ela envolva tudo o que a gente
ouviu e falou até agora enquanto nós
buscarmos enquanto nós buscamos receitas
prontas enquanto a gente busca segredo
baseado no sucesso dos outros
a gente segue extremamente desatentos na
observância daquilo que pode nos tornar
unidos
o nosso material genético é único
as nossas capacidades são únicas e não
faz sentido a gente seguir distraído por
aí olhando receitas e segredos prontos
que até podem ter feito sentido para
outras pessoas mas não necessariamente
vão ser o ingrediente da nossa receita
orgânico pessoas profissionais empresas
orgânicas são aquelas que conseguiram
ter um start na sua função da sua
atividade baseada no que a gente chama
de propósito e propósito vai muito mais
além daquilo que eu faço ou como eu faço
a propósito tem a ver com um
o que a gente faz nós podemos ter
atividades semelhantes
nós podemos fazer atividades homogêneas
parecidas umas com as outras
mas o nosso porque tem que ser nós não é
possível recuar nas outras pessoas
alguma coisa que não tenha primeiro e
quadro fazendo efeito um sentido muito
amplo e muito real
dentro de cada um de nós o propósito é o
nosso porque o nosso porque é nosso é
orgânico
o nosso porque está espelhado no porquê
de outras pessoas
não sei quantos de vocês já tiveram a
oportunidade de parar e olhar um
alimento que é orgânico e certamente a
gente vai encontrar uma fruta uma
verdura legumes em que ele não tem
aquele aspecto perfeito e bonito como a
gente está acostumado a ver
não parece ser a melhor fruta não parece
ser melhor verdura até às vezes parece
que tem alguma coisa de errado eu lembro
que a primeira vez que eu fui num
estabelecimento que serve de alimentação
orgânica e eu recebi uma pergunta no
mínimo inusitada da pessoa que veio é
nos atender à mesa a gente pediu um suco
de laranja ela disse vocês já tiveram
aqui não é a primeira vez que ela falou
então eu vou te alertar para que o nosso
suco de laranja diferente do que você
está acostumado quem sabe e eu
ingenuamente perguntei por que ela disse
porque aqui a nossa laranja laranja de
verdade é laranja orgânica e naquele
momento me dei conta eu me perguntei
puxa será que eu esqueci o que eu gosto
genuíno orgânico de um produto que o
consumo com tanta freqüência
e me parece que a gente esqueceu disso
assim como a gente esqueceu qual é o
sabor ea textura qual é a vitamina do
nosso jeito orgânico de fazer as coisas
a gente esquecer o que é uma empresa
orgânica
a gente está preocupado em construir
algo que aos olhos das pessoas chama a
atenção que quando tem algum machucado
naquela empresa naquela pessoa a gente
na hora de fazer a imagem a gente coloca
de um lado onde isso não apareça porque
a gente tem receio de se mostrar
organicamente
só que o que não é orgânico não é boa o
que não é orgânico não
frança não toca as pessoas negócios
profissionais orgânicos é necessário
primeiro fazer sentido para a gente para
que depois eu possa alcançar as outras
pessoas é necessário que foi tão forte
dentro de nós que quando e quatro outros
não incite as pessoas a nos limitar e
nos copiar
elas podem nos admirar elas podem ter
como inspiração mas essencialmente elas
vão reconhecer em nós
alguém que encontrou um propósito ea
motivação não vai ser a cópia a
motivação vai ser eu também quero
encontrar o meu propósito eu também
quero encontrar esse material genético
que eu já carrego dentro de mim
só que até então estou desprezando
muitas vezes em nome daquilo que eu acho
que a receita de sucesso vindo de outras
pessoas
nós começamos nos perguntando o que é
sucesso e cada um de nós deve responder
o que nós usamos como critério na
construção do nosso sucesso
eu gosto da palavra esforço porque é um
sintoma disse o caminho que a gente está
trilhando se as escolhas a gente está
fazendo as ações que a gente está
tomando elas realmente são verdadeiras
são genuínas e orgânicas a palavra
esforço ela como tantas outras que fazem
parte da nossa língua portuguesa vem do
latim em latim elas escrevem e xis ea
expressão esforçe ari força aérea bem
fácil bem rápido ea gente entender que
vem de força ea expressão e se em latim
com estes significa fora é por isso que
a gente fala com esse funcionário a
gente fala que a pessoa foi excomungada
de um lugar
ela está fora daquele lugar
o que é o esforço o esforço é colocar a
nossa força pra fora mas visão de
concordar que se a gente quer colocar
alguma coisa pra fora ela antes precisa
tá dentro e se no momento que a gente
condiciona os nossos esforços e as
nossas ações diárias a qualquer outra
coisa pode ser um sintoma de que o
propósito que a gente tenha escolhido
pra nossa vida
está bastante claro pode ser que ainda
há gente esteja trabalhando fazendo as
nossas ações diárias sem se dar conta do
genuíno propósito e cada um de nós tem
dentro de si e que a gente se perde
muitas vezes deslumbrado olhando o
propósito dos outros
deslumbrado buscando material genético
de terceiros enquanto a mais pura
linhagem do nosso sucesso tá dentro de
nós
quando o nosso propósito é nobre
o nosso esforço se torna altamente
orgânico ea consequência disso não é um
resultado extraordinário é um resultado
natural e quando a gente entrega um
resultado natural
o resultado chega primeiro é a gente
seja não que a gente faz pessoalmente ou
seja o que a gente faz profissionalmente
seja um dia para a gente refletir as
nossas escolhas são realmente nossas ou
a gente está vivendo muitas vezes de
material genético do sucesso dos outros
o nosso dia seja orgânico e quando a
gente tiver o privilégio de encontrar
outras pessoas com esse mesmo propósito
nós possamos nos reconhecer e dizer que
com certeza a gente está no caminho
certo
muitíssimo obrigado
[Aplausos]